this video is brought to you by
manscape.com
manscape is the premier brand for men's
grooming products and
accessories they have everything you
need to level up
your full body grooming game i really
like manscape because it's the go-to
place to get yourself
cleaned up so i don't like shopping very
much
so when i have to like clean my balls
clean my nose hairs
clean my nails i can trust manscaped on
sending me a package
and i can have and i can cover all of my
hygiene needs and i owe it to manscape
that it increases my [ __ ]
getting abilities hygiene is very
important
that's why we recommend their perfect
package 3.0 it comes with the lawnmower
3.0 body trimmer
look at that one baby it's waterproof
and it has
advanced skin safe technology to prevent
nicks cuts and accidentally ouchies
they got ball deodorant and ball toner
to keep your balls feeling so
fresh they smell manly too and also it
comes with a magic mat to catch
all your little pubies when you trim if
you enroll in the manscaped
peak hygiene plan you'll never have to
worry about these items running out
you will get quarterly replenishments of
your favorite products and trimming
blades sent to your door
hassle free go to www dot
jk news to get 20 off plus free
international shipping what
international yeah
go check out the link in the description
because your balls will
thank you very much
[Music]
did you guys hear that in manhattan
i mean manhattan's chinatown there were
over 500
asian american seniors that were given
these loud
alarm devices for their protection
because there's been so
many like hate crimes happening right
now because of covid
they're targeting asians heavily so they
recently did this whole protest in march
because this lady got uh like
they they put gasoline on her litter on
fire or something oh my god
oh yeah i have i have a photo of her
her shirt yeah so there was this 89 year
old woman who just set foot outside of
her home and then these two people
came up to her pushed her for no [ __ ]
reason
slapped her and yeah slapped her pushed
her
and then she turned around they lit her
her back
with the match yeah with a lighter it's
[ __ ] up
isn't that crazy that new york is like a
multicultural place
and like you would think that there's a
lot more acceptance or understanding
that's great and then the people that
are doing it like
the the the racism that's happening to
them
it's just all colors man like it's not
you imagine it's like this like
kkk white guy when you think racism
right yeah but it's
it's all different cultures that are
doing it to these
asians yeah it's for the chinese ladies
or whatever it's
crazy chinese people are like very easy
targets though
i think from through the eyes of another
people yeah yeah
it's just like i mean like just asians
in general i think have a stereotype for
being
quieter and less confrontational right
and then you add the age on top of that
and it's just like an easy target yeah
and it's so lame
is it easier i mean yeah it makes it
easier but like that makes it more of a
target
because they're yeah because they don't
need to target so it's like if you're if
you're
if you're a criminal right like you
don't want to rob a big guy
well yeah i get that you wanna you wanna
old lady and grab her person run with it
right kind of thing well there's a
different trying to like steal something
from oldie versus
burning them or slapping them no no so
so let's say you're an angry coward
right if you're angry weak [ __ ]
coward and you hate
a group you're not gonna go to the most
biggest tattooed meanest dude
you're not gonna find [ __ ] yeah
you're not gonna get
a yao ming and throw gassing on his ass
right
you're gonna find a child you're gonna
find an old lady you're gonna find
something
and [ __ ] them up and then feel good
about it because
they themselves the people that are
doing this are weak as [ __ ] yeah they
have to prey
on to make themselves feel dope yeah
yeah it's like the guys that beat up
girls on the street or rape them and all
that is because they're weak themselves
you know like they're cowards
and this is like it's not even a race
thing either because like
i i've read like we've come across so
many articles in like brooklyn and stuff
where like
like these youths are just going around
punching old people not knocking them
out and stuff like that one punch like
let's see what happens you just punch an
old guy or or a homeless guy
and that's just like a thing that's
happening in new york it's like a prank
culture
prank culture yeah it's not even asian
people though it's like it's
no that's been around for a while it's
called one punch knockout
yeah i mean i remember like people were
doing it when i was a kid and it's like
you try to
knock people out in one punch and then
guys would just like
run up to random people on the street
and then they just
try to wail on them and then and then
you win the game
if you could knock them out with one
hand why don't they just join a boxing
class
because they're cowards dude like think
about it they're they're little [ __ ]
like it's
crazy that they that they even they film
it and upload it like
yeah a lot of videos to do that though
and they're probably also picking like
easy prey you know well they go to the
they don't do it in front of them or
start they just run them they sucker
punch people
yeah yeah that's horrible but it's like
really heartbreaking though
that they like this is happening to the
point where now they're
they're giving elderly people
these allow like loud alarm it's like a
little remote that once you press it
like oh i think 125 decibels holy [ __ ]
does that make the grandma deaf too
though she probably
is that candy it's like you gotta take
out your hearing aid first
so they're like you can get your candy
and you can get your like alarm meter so
you're just sucking on a lollipop
they need that in like la for like the
in the hispanic communities because
they've been getting robbed like the
people
oh my god yeah i recently
oh like the ice cream guy yeah i heard
about like that hello
oh [ __ ] getting attacked the ice cream
man street vendors
yeah why are they getting attacked
though they have nothing to do with the
virus
just because people are desperate i
don't know they have a lot of rage that
needs but then it's like
they film them too so like the guys will
be in the car they'll pull over like oh
let me get a
like uh like candy whatever and they
pull out the money to give them change
and then they like start beating the
show you mean the guy that's pushing the
cart yeah or or not the
ice cream truck girls no no like it's
been mostly like the street vendors just
like
all types of people what the cart ones
yeah i know i mean they bring so much
joy and [ __ ] they're like here's a
popsicle there's a lot of [ __ ] out
there
and they're just angry or something
[Music]
taking it out on
people that i [ __ ] just they're
another thing those are the kind of
people that just like
kick dogs and like stomp on like
straight cats is there like a group of
vigilantes that like get together and
find these people on social media and
just go and [ __ ] them up
yeah yeah that's i mean that's how
people are getting like you know the
kids that like
are doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] or these races
or whatever like they get recorded right
um and then everyone doxes them but
like these guys specifically they were
out to
burn somebody or [ __ ] people up because
they were covered up
like they knew they were going out to
commit crime that day yeah yeah
exactly so they never got caught not
that i know
i don't think i don't think so so
there's there's like the only treating
it as a hate crime by the way
oh [ __ ] the club like the the the
burning one
they're not treating that as a hate
crime because they're saying that these
assailants they didn't
they didn't say any uh derogatory terms
to the point where
they can determine that this was
race-based so that's why it's not a
hate crime or even old people which
one's worse if they get locked up hate
crime or a
burn pyro crime i don't know because
whatever is the worst one i would i
would want well
if you could stack the crime the more
you can stack the crimes
the more time they'll go so like
they're it's already a given like it
just because they label
it a hate crime doesn't mean that
they're gonna take away that there's an
assault that happened in a [ __ ]
arse or not arson but like you know even
like trying to burn somebody attempted
murder whatever right
so um hate crime kind of adds
to the to guys yeah so they could stay
longer in jail if they get convicted
but then it's hard to prove so what yeah
the thing is like it's not that the cops
don't want to like they also
want to uh increase their chances of
success so here's the thing like if you
throw these charges at them and it all
they don't stick because you can't prove
it
then they might just go free yeah or the
entire thing
yep versus it's like the uh the game man
it's hard
top killers instead of like you know
hitting them with first degree murder if
you get them with third or second degree
then there's a higher chance of actually
sticking the punishment yep
um which is why it turns into a giant
legal battle
it and it's harder to prove if they if
these people
like blatantly i think it was targeted
because it's like who's gonna go and
burn an old chinese lady and whatever
right but then at the same time
if they didn't literally say those words
if they didn't say them it's difficult
to prove by the way i realized i just
said cop killers not the cop killers
the cops that kill people yeah yeah
yeah yeah so this is the nine-year-old
well now she's 90.
she's here in the middle i'm so glad she
started china mac right there
he's from new york right yeah i'm
assuming
there was this like march recently like
what joe was saying
and pretty much trying to call for
justice
for what she went through because it
doesn't seem like anything's really
getting done
man i recently saw two like um there was
a
a bunch of armed like chinese folks in
chinatown like that
like in a line when that whole coveted
racism thing was going on and i was like
that's pretty crazy that they had to
it's kind of like the rooftop koreans
you know you have to kind of stand there
and do that but they can't be
everywhere and then there's this other
group remember we did a jk news on it
was called like the guardian angels or
whatever
yeah yeah they came out and they were
patrolling chinatown i think they were a
community watch group that started in
like the 60s but they got all these red
berets and [ __ ]
and then um so it seems like there
is support but not enough right there's
not enough people there to help
that's and then that's crazy man
or at least like yeah there's not enough
being done by
those like the authorities like those in
charge and that's why people are just
fed up and you're just upset like why
why isn't
anything being done or why aren't
uh citizens being better protected and
this is looking really bad for the
triads by the way because you guys are
supposed to [ __ ]
the whole race is true actually they pay
extortion
is so you guys [ __ ] run the streets
and keep these [ __ ] out
specifically in chinatown manhattan yeah
yeah they are
from all the chinatowns though the tongs
yeah so like historically the tongs
which are the
original term for these chinatown gangs
they were
the chinese mafia they're supposed to
benevolent group of people that would
protect chinese people
in chinatown because there were cops
back in the day like in the 1800s and
early 1900s
wouldn't actually patrol the streets of
chinatown because they're like oh you
guys are asian chinese [ __ ]
like
who cares not white who cares about you
guys so then they needed to form their
own
alliance of protection and that's where
the tongs came from
and then now they kind of morphed into
triads and through the 80s they kind of
went through their whole
like not so bright uh era
what what that about well they just went
from being a benevolent group of
protecting people to just being a
full-on gang
you know over over time what if what if
wha
what if the reason why they're having
this is because all those
um gangs went to jail so there's nobody
overseeing
chinatown anyone got locked up you know
so now all these old people need to get
together and be a
gang you know what i mean yeah like kung
fu hustle like kung fu hustle the axe
gangs
yeah no they need to be like the old
people that beat the axe game oh yeah
like the the lady who smells cigarette
and just beats people
yeah and the shower cat guy and her lazy
husband
yeah that movie was so good it's a
it's a really weird time uh in general
and
i don't even really know how to touch on
this topic too much but just being like
an asian american during this year right
because like have you ever felt uh
racism because of all this stuff this
year or no
uh me personally i haven't gotten racism
because of like the coronavius or
anything like that
um i've experienced racism in general
but it's nothing crazy maybe like i told
you i actually talked about last time
here
like that homeless person who like
yelled at me but like it's a homeless
person yeah he might just be crazy
exactly but i just feel like there's
such a weird line
or a space of limbo that like asian
americans kind of like live in right now
uh whether it and it's not a complaint i
just life is what it is but right it's
like being
the model minority is one way that is
both a good thing and a bad thing at the
same time
right being an asian american is like
both a good thing and a bad thing at the
same time since you're not really from
asia but at the same time you're
associated with anything that is bad in
asia
and so it's just kind of kind enough for
some reason exactly it's just this
weird limbo where things are like cool
and not cool at the same time
i think we're like they don't even know
what to make of us that's what i'm
saying it's like
it's like i know black people i know
mexicans but
you wait i forgot you were here yeah you
know what's really interesting
is um because case and i always talk
about this sometimes where
it's like uh asians in america they
didn't
like you guys haven't necessarily gotten
like a culture kind of thing because you
know like for
mexicans like there's like the chicano
culture culture
and all that stuff but yeah it started
off lighthearted in a sense that i was
like there's always
an american version of an accent of any
minority group
like mexicans have like the american
mexican accent
or like italians have the italian
american accent and you can kind of say
that for most people
like you know i guess uh ebonics you
know and like and then even like within
the white people like there's like
you know from their heritage like they
have a certain type of
twang to how they speak but chinese
people don't necessarily have that right
asian people don't know that's called
pidgin in hawaii
true but it only lives in hawaii and
it's more of a hawaiian thing rather
than like
the asian thing you know what i mean
like i don't know we don't have and so
we started off with accents but then we
started talking about culture and then
and i'm like yeah like asian american
culture is not very
identified as of yet or maybe we're
still in the process of
we're in the process of finding it right
now i see it in comedy in different
times right comedy yes
when you talk about like vietnamese hair
salons when you talk about you know
uh just old chinese people when you're
talking about
you know and like food or whatever you
know those accents are very
clear when anybody makes fun of like a
korean accent real quick it's very easy
so that's coming directly from
korea right like people from those
countries speaking english though right
using
using but it's like fobby accents rather
than a
home american grown uh i understand
like the chicano accent is different
from a spanish speaking accent yeah
if you if you're imitating if through
comedy's lens right like if you're
trying to emulate a mexican accent from
from someone from mexico it's it's
different from a chicano accent
you know but chicano accent make no
mistake is going to be a mexican
heritage thing
but we don't necessarily have that as
asians would you want an asian american
i'm not saying i want that but like
but it's just interesting to notice that
there isn't yeah and i feel like there's
something about that that also
feels like as asian americans we're also
kind of too dispersed and not
as unified as other minorities are and i
think that's also with because there's
not that like centralized
culture or identity yet that could also
be why you just see
asians like siding with the ones that
are closer
you know like there's like more there's
like asians that grew up in like
um like with more black people have more
black demeanor or
with more hispanics have more hispanic
demeanor or other one they
they have more like like silicon valley
demeanor because we don't have
our theme just yet well maybe there's
also like uh the asians also
i mean there's obviously ones that come
together but then there's ones that like
korean stick with koreans there's so
many different subgroups of
yeah is mexican even though they're
latin next
so south west culture is mainly a lot of
mexicans and then south central
central uh latins came in like in the
80s
and on yeah and then florida you just
think of cubans or like right or like
puerto ricans in new york or whatever so
they're
i think they do have the same type of
diversity we do but they have a common
language that brings them together where
we have
uh no common culture yeah so it's almost
like
you there is like a japanese american
experience
right yes that we just so happen to kind
of look similar
but then in the past for many many years
there was the chinese community
there was the japanese community and
they didn't really like
mix as asian community yeah maybe it's
hard to do like a universal like just
yeah
asian we'll get there in probably like
four or five more generations though
right because like right now it's very
clear
especially except for like the japanese
generations that have been here for
longer
you know yeah with many of the asians
we're all like first generation
but once like you know mingling and
generations passed down where like
chinese people or japanese people get
together like vietnamese people korean
or whatever
because even if asians do stick with
other asians right right
eventually because we look at like for
example white people in america and most
of those people have no idea where they
came from
you know what i'm saying so we all kind
of know yeah we all still know but like
maybe four or five generations from now
they might
not really know yeah what asian they
came from
and a lot of asian americans like
japanese or chinese like whatever
i like i have friends who are like seven
eight generations long right
but they marry within the group like
like one of my friends like he's an east
coast chinese dude his
great grandpa came to boston or new york
and they kept marrying chinese women
from china
even during the exclusion act yeah and
then so japanese americans too for
the longest time like they would just
marry other japanese and i think that's
why
hawaii is probably the best example
where
they have their own thing like hawaii
like
like hawaiians like they're mixed
they're japanese chinese portuguese
whatever
and then they have their own thing and
then they don't relate even back to asia
so i think that is probably maybe the
future for us
20 plus years ago freaking america yeah
yeah but i think that's probably a huge
thing about
asian american culture is just that it's
been kind of these satellite groups
yeah throughout america yeah and then so
you will have chinese american culture
that's very distinct and that's
been around for a while like they've
been around like
as as long as the filipino like culture
like since
100 years ago or whatever right yeah and
then you have a
japanese culture on the west coast but
still it's it's
it's isolated there's no like
togetherness and you have asian history
and dissension amongst nations and that
[ __ ] gets passed down it does
not only gets passed down still because
we're still even in america like younger
asian generations so it's like you're
still
taught of like your nation's or your
culture's history and like how
this country came in and [ __ ] your
[ __ ] up or like you know what i'm saying
so
it's just different
[Music]
[Music]
you